soixante deux ans l'artiste sculpteur de
glace laurent godon a vu neiger dans ma
testament et rend un autre temps tout
cela peut être cinq de griffer la glace
varie toujours un mot les deux jouent ça
peut être humain donc faut travailler
sans conséquence c'est lui qui a
remporté quatre fois le titre des
sculpteurs le plus rapide du monde dans
le livre guinness des records en est à
sa 3ème fête des neiges
selon lui au pâtissier il faut avoir un
don c'est vraiment un monsieur de dota
l'homme mélanger ensemble qui font en
sorte qu' on peut réussir à avoir un
visuel conditions météo difficiles
travail précaire et exigent peu de
québécois pratiquent cette forme d'art
professionnellement le jeudi 8 à 10 à
peu près lors plus ou moins beaucoup de
techniciens autour du sun le sculpteur
du temps d'environ 8 à 10 à peu près de
meetic et co2 de vivre de s'auto jour
d'aujourd'hui
bon je les fais fait donc ses traits
mines m
à l'aube de la retraite laurent godon
passe maintenant la ch'ti mécanique à
son fils nicolas qui a pris la relève de
l'entreprise
en plus de réaliser 18 glissade
construite complètement glace est un
bateau très jeune artiste s'amusera
faire une démonstration de sa créativité
je quitte un bloc alentours d'une
dizaine de minutes pour vraiment le met
plein la vue et pour laurent godon le
bonheur passe par la transmission des
connaissances d'accord avec nico puis ça
continue comme ça c'est vraiment bon la
récompense ici julie jocelyne boudreault
aller canada montréal